[Music]
the white house has been the residents
of every president since the second John
Adams but though it's today the center
of national attention that hasn't always
been the case during most of the 19th
century the country was far more
interested in what was happening in
Congress on Capitol Hill than what was
happening here at the White House but we
live today in a presidential age so much
so that many Americans think that the
president is in charge of national
affairs that's a perception that the
political scientist Hugh heckle calls
the illusion of presidential government
now to be sure the presidency today is
far more powerful than it was in the
19th century government is much larger
and the president oversees a large
number of executive agencies as well the
United States is a major player on the
world stage that brings the presidency
to the forefront yet the reality is the
presidency operates in a system of
divided powers the presidency is one
branch of the national government the
president can propose legislation but
unless Congress goes along there is no
law that's the reality of the American
system Theodore Roosevelt one of the
great twentieth century presidents said
it best I wish if only for a day to be
Congress as well as the president then
said Roosevelt I'd truly be in charge of
the national government